hello reject nation I'm Greg and I'm
John I want to be more like John so I
have a ponytail today trend-setting
John gets all the ladies I do and this
it's not this is getting the ladies
right here yes it wasn't until I grew
this hair out for a couple years that
come I only started coming to you know
that way you got long hair a lot more
girls started liking you I don't know
maybe I have a really kind of patently
poor gauge for those kinds of things I
do well you have a great gauge for those
kinds of things with regular life yeah
come up to me after like half of our
social outings like she was so Indian
I'd be like why don't she jumps your
bones you know uh by that time mr. Ghana
that last move you know got a corners
some kind of market hey guys his he has
done a how thor ragnarok should have
ended oh boy and in the devil's anus or
whatever you know we got to check this
out all right
oh so patron of the day shout out today
gonna go out to Erica Tuesday hey cuz
she is an artist and she did you roles a
lot so therefore since this is Adam ated
I figured it's fit for your shoutout
[Music]
rappers shucks
[Music]
[Music]
how'd you like a job sure excellent
then you can start by grabbing that
sword right away I did the key to this
whole thing so if we want to be the kind
of it's stolen
[Music]
everyone this is just a minor setback
all we need to do is extricate ourselves
free finish
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
or thirsty thirsty
was that that's actually a great joke
it's pretty good
yeah it's a good pun cuz he's Thor and
he's thirsty pretty good you could say
Thor likes bragging to rock a little bit
yeah it could say that Thor likes to get
hammered like we hammered the most why
are we writing for these guys really we
have the skills aren't we in frothing
these off the top I mean this was one of
the ones where I was like oh yeah this
seemed kind of like a thing that might
have happened especially the first one
where she just like destroys the ship
the first one seems like the most likely
that could have happened yeah when I was
watching
I did start having that thought why
didn't she just do that she could have
brought the ship down herself doing
something along those lines but the
Doctor Strange one - yeah
they when you introduce a character like
Doctor Strange into this movie you're
like can't he just show up and magic
space I know the point of the first
movie is sort of like no you can't just
undo everything but you know that joke
about when Loki is falling into that
abyss for like a long-ass time and then
he detects that there was a person from
another dimension coming in here another
portal coming through he could have
detected that too with hella and helped
out in that situation as well so when
you just have that scene with Doctor
Strange and then you hop to this one I
don't know there's probably a lot more
rules to it yeah but in terms of what I
remember from the movie it does make me
go this seems like it could have
actually yeah yeah
Doctor Strange just shown up especially
if they're having that meeting on this
is Earth Reyes yeah he could have helped
out a little bit I'm sure he's in a
position to know just how much of a head
right hella is that Justice League jab
was cool I felt that one yeah at the
table with Batman and soups and all too
bold thing to say but uh you know it's
Loki man it's what he does you could say
he's a little jokey you yeah and you
might say that he's pretty low-key in
his villainy which is how he's able to
like sneak away with Tessa Rex's yeah
[Applause]
that's why you come to this channel
that's what we do
honan it up that's us fleshing out our
stand-up comedy material why go to
flappers comedy in Burbank well we could
just experiment here before this video
wraps up shout out today to Erika
Tuesday
Erika Tuesday is a wonderful wonderful
artist yeah a delightful soul great
human being I want you to sit down right
now and and sit back from your computer
and just pat yourself on the back cuz
you know what you're hard-working you
got one of the biggest hearts of anybody
I know you're always looking out for
peeps you know you gotta look for out
for yourself a bit you guys self-love
fire up that hot tub just have yourself
a big old soup of relaxation because
you've earned it we
love ya there you go that's a hard house
that is that shoutout go check out her
art - Erica Tuesday art on the
Facebook's are you gonna mention that my
girlfriend I want to have a threesome oh
yeah I'm basically trying to be match
calm before everybody so I have the
ponytail today yeah you know it's a new
look for you it's a chance to make a
different impression I think it's
working
if you're just asking me if she has
given my girlfriend's number I'll give
her your girlfriend's number I'll make
sure this is it for that zit happen
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects look that notification bell
subscribe to his head and check her
picture yeah it's like a second youtube
channel and there's a bike over 300
exclusive posts and also much of our
extra goodies for higher rewards years
as well check it out